someone running upstairs on all fours
would give me the ick strongly disagree
I think it's funny yeah but are they
conscious of it are they doing it let me
quickly go upstairs and was like I I'm
just going to go
[Laughter]
upstairs down the stairs and
all that would be weird sorry I was just
using bathro but would you not think it
would be the funniest thing so say
somebody's like who going upstairs and
they did it on you thought it was on
ironic and like a day later they' be
like you know that was a joke that would
be hilarious that would be you married
yeah yeah 100% what about like sliding
down them when your bum that gives me
more the ick CU it's not as funny it's
just a bit weird yeah and what you have
to sort of less of a big gesture you be
like it's your bum I've broken my cockx
exactly exactly